this is andy's apple farm this is
eastwood thomas eastwood if you're
hearing this welcome to the beta test of
andy's apple farm okay as a beta tester
your goal is to find bugs and glitches
and report them to me okay i'm fully
aware the game is not finished however i
will update the game as time goes on
thank you beta tester
press the spacebar to play okay
what is this
[Music]
well that's not good well
we're off to a good start i feel
confident about this
oh what did i just see i didn't see it
lixie and play it
i back see into the past
well yes i can if i use my memories
anyway
so is it
is it just this one that's broken
no
i really want to go to this game
[Music]
ah
well i guess i can't do that
critical process died
i don't know if that's exactly what you
mean okay let's try this game
ah
[Music]
wow
hi
this is looking so good
hi i'm andy the apple hi
welcome to my apple farm
to move around just press the arrow keys
on your keyboard you can talk with
others by pressing the space bar let's
go see how everyone is doing today yeah
let's let's see how everyone is doing
today
i'm gonna go see how everyone is doing
today
great
[Music]
uh there's no one here
andy there seems to be no one here
i mean your apple farm is very spacious
and wonderful and all
all the apple seeds on the ground are
just a delight but it seems like you've
kind of half picked all your apples
i feel like it would be in your best
interest to
pick all of them in a section and go
row by row or something like that
hi
hello
what's up oh hi andy we're just having a
picnic i thought you were a grape you're
a fish
hello i have felix melody margaret klaus
klaus so what are you all up to today
oh we're just eating right now care for
an apple
[Music]
uh
hey after we eat we should play some
games okay andy do you want to play with
us
of course i would
perfect each of us has a bonus sticker
with all of our bonus stickers we'll
give you a prize what do you mean
oh wow what's the prize
that would break the surprise would it
not
oh yeah i guess you are it's the key to
your house
you took the key to my house yeah we did
but but why would you gotta get all the
bonus stickers together all the bonus
stickers to get it back
yeah don't fret this will be fun
well if you guys say so let's play some
games yeah let's play some games i like
hello oh my god you were approaching me
way too fast what are you doing what are
you doing
ah you're the fishman
you go to the fish zone
okay klaus
what is it uh
that you're doing here go talk to melody
first where is melody i don't know
i don't know where melody went i wasn't
looking melody is it a humility or you a
margaret melody or margaret hey andy i
was picking up fruits but drop them all
can you help me sort them into the right
baskets
yeah
no oh okay maybe in a little bit then
okay fine
yes can you help me
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes i really
appreciate your help you're welcome
wait i didn't
did i say yes or that or did it
automatically do that eric's to move
your hand grab the fruit
[Music]
okay yeah just like that just like that
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm having so much fun
i'm having so much fun
you can tell by my smile just how much
fun i am having
[Music]
oh no oh that was the wrong basket
do i have to do that
i'm gonna have fun
can you help me pour them into the right
baskets
oh boy i get to have fun all over again
we
let's see if you're having fun too right
you're contractually obligated to have
fun
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hmm
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you so much for helping me out
andy you're welcome
i didn't earn this
okay whatever
sure thing
thank you melody
melody the
beaver
hi margaret are you a moon or something
hi andy do you want to play a song with
me play a song sure
yeah awesome just let me grab that
guitar and we'll play okay what am i
gonna play arrow keys to play no miss a
note and you lose play the song to win
am i supposed to play that i don't am i
am i supposed to memorize this somehow
am i supposed to understand what this
[Music]
but it wasn't even to the beat okay i
gotta not listen to the beat because
it's gonna throw me entirely off
[Music]
here we go
okay
[Music]
hey all those years of ddr really helped
me out oh wow you're good at playing the
guitar here's a bonus sticker for all
your hard work what was that you kind of
messed up there you want to try that
okay goodbye
you shine so bright your beauty moon pie
sky high whatever
fly die
cry
my me oh my
you get me you understand
why why why why why why why why lie
dying in the high high high high lie in
my thigh uh i'm gonna cry
oh no an irregularity has occurred
please restart the game escape
[Music]
what is happening what's happening what
is happening
what's happening
what am i hearing i don't know what's
going on
i don't know why
and i don't know what i'm hearing
but i don't know if this is leading
anywhere if this is
what is happening
somebody's knocking out a door someone's
walking upstairs or coming to the door
what
what's happening okay so this is just a
random ass guess but if this is
something about like the game programmer
is here
and these sounds are them coming home
for some reason i don't know why
[Applause]
what is that
i'm gonna i'm gonna go now because i
don't know if this is actually reaching
any conclusion and i have to restart the
game for realsies this time it's not one
of those fake crashes this is a real
crash hello uh this is eastwood thomas
eastwood if you're hearing this welcome
to the beta test of andy's apple farm is
that different as a beta tester your
goal is to find bugs and glitches and
report them to me no it's the same i
will update the game it's the same i
think maybe unless it wasn't
it might have been the same i don't know
okay i don't remember saving but
apparently it's one of those auto save
things
hello again
i guess i'll go to see clowns
[Music]
hi
hello okay i'm gonna go see klaus unless
klaus wants me to see the fish man first
hello ah no here we go why hello there
andy
don't you have a game for me to play
oh yes uh what about a game of chess
chess i have no idea how to play that
oh okay uh how about a game of ice spy
sounds good to me let's play
what
i spy move your hands it's like a right
object i spy with my little eye
something red red apple apple yes that's
it
i spy with my little eye something
floating floating you're talking about a
leaf on a pond or a towel or something
that's it yes i spy with my little eye
something growing
you're talking about this little tree
that's grown over here yes that's it
i spy with my little eye something
dangerous oh you're talking about this
axe over here unless you're talking
about the building which represents man
and their infinite capacity for evil
how about the axe which also represents
yes that's it i spy with my little eye
something
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
cece
got your nose
oh okay
i'm klaus now
i'm gonna go over here now
this is my house this is my burnt down
ramp
there is no need for this whatever this
is whatever this may be whatever is
happening here
[Laughter]
look out behind you class
oh
where are they arthur
whoa you need to calm down man
i i don't know oh man
put the accent what are you doing
i'm sick and tired are you lying to me
hit him with the
ah please don't don't do it
you kill them
ow
ow
ah
i think he might be dead bro
[Music]
oh my god what have i done uh you just
killed him
thought that was obvious
good job at playing that game
for your reward i'll give you my bonus
sticker thanks really appreciate it
big preach huge preach actually if you
think about it it's the biggest priest
you've ever preached
it's mega priest okay hey fish man i
don't remember your name but uh do you
have a sticker for me you want to play a
fishing game or something dude how's it
going
oh you know it bro yeah that's more like
it let's play
yeah oh
catch three fish okay got it
got it
nailed
it hey good job you caught a fish
i did
okay how am i supposed to
there we go
got it okay perfect
nailed
[Music]
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute oh that's a boot
that's not a fish
better looking next time what do you
talk how in the world did that get the
boot and not the fish it was definitely
more boot more fish than building a
fishing game yeah i do yeah that's more
like it let's play let's play
let's do the damn thing
hey good job
hey thanks man really appreciate it why
am i not glitching this time
[Music]
you caught a fish oh no i'm glitching
hey good job you got fear
[Music]
what was that about an xbox did you say
something about nx hi hello who are you
why are you here
but it wasn't her fault what what wasn't
her fault what are you talking about
where am i what is this
what is any of this but hi
hey good job man here's a bonus sticker
just for you
thanks man thank you i'm on my way from
this hellscape of a lake
all right bro i got four bonus stickers
i'm gonna be able to get the keys to my
own house i think
um
is klaus like the uh
[Music]
so where are my keys yeah where are they
oh they're just in there
oh
it's kind of dark isn't it just go right
ahead don't be scared
yeah just go get your keys
well if you guys say so
yeah if you guys say so
how can i
you make make way excuse me
excuse oh
boy i'm gonna
well it's been lovely gang but
apparently i gotta go in this barn which
is a totally normal thing to do and
nothing ominous could possibly be about
this i'll be out in a mome once i get my
keys
take care of chica for me okay bye
hey guys i can't see anything in here
how am i supposed to find my keys yeah
how am i supposed to find my keys guys
guys
hey wait no guys
why would you do that
oh boy i'm gonna have to find the light
i'm gonna sure
oh get to the fourth area when avoid the
eyes
[Music]
but i am eyes
[Music]
i am eyes
[Music]
okay so it's like a three by three space
and i need to avoid some eyes
i went eyes eyes eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
eyes
that was a bad time for that to glitch
out on me
that was a bad time
eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes on
the prize eyes on the prize eyes on the
prize eyes on the prize
[Music]
i thought it normally would do that
wouldn't it would it not
the future
[Music]
i have a lantern
oh
hi who are you who are you who are you
who are you who are you who are you wait
wait who are you
i'm peter the pumpkin nice to meet you
wait how long have you been in here yeah
how long have you been in here that
doesn't matter
you want to play a game of tag
no
i'm just looking for my keys sounds
great let's play just this way to the
haystack maze
wait who even are you
okay you're it catch me if you can
i'll catch you
i'm gonna get you
you're not gonna get away from me
oh
you better hurry up oh i i get it i'm
probably gonna have to cut him off at a
pass
i'm not gonna be able to get him from
just chasing him but i need to get a
better understanding of this whole maze
before what is this
what is it what is that supposed to be
i bet this connects up it doesn't okay
i'm screwed
[Music]
tunes
i'm just gonna
guess he's gonna come up this way and
i'm gonna oh
oh you've been gone
[Applause]
run away if you can
haha you'll never catch me
i'm too fat ass for you i don't know
where you are i don't know where you are
i don't know where you are and i don't
know why you are why are you and where
are you i can't see anything where are
you where are where are you
that's the that's that
oh this seems unfair
god this seems extremely unfair
uh
my dude
[Music]
well
this is fun okay hey what's up
oh
am i supposed to be doing something or
are you communing with this thing are
you
oh hi um
i'm very confused i don't necessarily
know what's going on here and i don't
know why
um
oh i'm being deleted
i think i need to submit a few bug
reports to the developer uh there seems
to be some issues with this game and uh
it's not quite um
not quite what i was imagining when i um
uh
signed up for the beta testing i think
oh i'm here
i see
my key
is
my keys
what i got myself into
uh
you can help me whoa whoa
whoa i ah
save a save me save us
how do i
i
are those eyes are those emeralds
beautiful collectibles
[Music]
great
oh good okay um
is that actually the end or is this just
some kind of a trick
[Music]
because i could believe it being either
way
i guess that's it
that was pretty good
honestly i mean i was more confused than
anything in all these like horror
experiences sometimes just like create
more questions and answers but it looks
like there's going to be a chapter too
so that should be very fun uh to see
where the hell this is going because it
does seem like there is a bit of a story
here like there are context clues and
there are those cut scenes and the
murdering and the acts and the woods and
the forest and the apple farm in general
and all these other characters i'm
willing to bet that there's something to
this
what happens if you go back
[Music]
hey good job man i see
okay so nothing there all right well
very good game
i had a blast very spooky and i think
that there's a lot of potential there so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below uh
if you like apples
and andy
imagine i came up with a really clever
way of tying this into distractible or
go my favorite sports team the links of
which are in the description below thank
you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you